ja hallo und herzlich willkommen tsum
videoweb preis 2015
heute werden die nominierung bekannt
gegeben und wir freuen uns dass ihr so
zahlreich erschienen seid ja auch ein
herzliches willkommen von mir nicht nur
die nominierten werden bekannt geben
sondern es gibt auch schon ein paar
gewinne
wir fangen wir nicht gleich an mit den
gewinnern in der kategorie berliner
youtube
der preis geht an alle berliner youtuber
hinbekommt kommen wir auch schon zum
nächsten direkten preis der preis für
den besten verein auf youtube geht an
und bitte die kölner haben sich
beschwert
ok alternative gut
aufgrund vieler werbung haben wir uns
für eine alternative nominierung
entschieden
kommen wir auch zur ersten kategorie
was ist das wichtigste auto richtig
wachstum aber nicht nur in der kategorie
reichweite sind nominiert franck weiter
die und kontor applaus
aber reichweite reicht nicht weiß wenn
nämlich die richtigen aufruf zahlen hast
die nominierten in der kategorie views
sind krank titz mit und kontor und wenn
die views und die reichweite stimmen
dann kommt es nur noch darauf an
verkaufen verkaufen verkaufen und in der
kategorie zählt sie partnern sind
nominiert lions mit seinem album löwen
kind des beauty palace mit der michael
kors uhr und natürlich sami slimani mit
dem slimani prinzip applaus applaus
so jetzt wird es romantisch
die nominierten in der kategorie bestes
youtuber pärchen sind da die und laien
baby und julian und chris und shirin
wie jetzt jemand anders
okay die letzten nominierten sind
philipp steuer und media kraft die auch
nicht ach so ok nach 1 gleich nicht
verständnis ist natürlich fehler steuer
und sein kupfer funktion nicht nur vor
der kamera sondern auch live sind sie
jeden cent wert
in der kategorie tour sind nominiert
lions mit seiner tour zum album löwen
kind die gang mit der gänge tour und als
letztes baby und julian mit der baby und
julia tour applaus ich bin so stolz
dieses jahr den ehrenpreis verleihen zu
dürfen
erst sprach er sich dagegen aus in der
jury zu sitzen und dann hat er sich noch
über das ergebnis beschwert andere
schüler verdient
auch im letzten jahr wurden wir wieder
mit dem kreativsten und witzigsten
format auf youtube überhäuft die top
drei nominierten in der kategorie
challenges sind sascha von den
aussenseitern mit der vertrauten ihr
challenge gabi heller mit der extremen
smoothie kämen und baby mit der wer
traut sich mehr challenge youtube kann
man sich heute gar nicht mehr ohne musik
vorstellen oder also ja es geht hand in
hand und deshalb gibt es in unserer
nächsten kategorie die müsse lumpen
musik parodien und die nominierten sind
mit der parodie zu rock mit der parodie
zu happy und zu der parodie zu what ever
wrapped applaus
kommen wir auch schon zum nächsten
gewinner der gewinner in der kategorie a
script ist mit ihrem chaos redstone dort
beweisen sie uns immer wieder was ein
wirklich gut geschriebenes format wenn
nicht sogar das beste format auf youtube
ausmacht herr inglewood der nächste
direkte preis für den youtube geht an
channels er hat uns mit diesen tweet
bewiesen wir sind keine videokünstler
wir sind youtuber fleiß gute arbeit ein
richtiges ergebnis das zählt alles nicht
wir sollten wieder back to the roots
gehen und sehen was mal einem youtuber
wahr machen wir uns noch richtig zum
affen vor der kamera danke channels für
diese offenbarung kann man eigentlich
anders
youtube und musik passt das wirklich
zusammen
ich sage ja denn dieser künstler hat es
bewiesen
der preis an sound geht an lions mit dem
album the case kreativität fleiß das
technische know-how eigene idee das
alles braucht unsere person auch für
jede mail alles mit julian grupp ist
dass man im sturm babys seien fans
erobern kann
und mit dieser leistung zeigt er uns ein
das ist nicht darauf ankommt dieselben
dich kein hengst sondern wie tief du ihn
rein steckst danke julia
aufgrund von diesem tweet von 100 arco
haben uns entschieden auch dieses jahr
schien david zur wahl zu stellen wenn
eine die förderung braucht dann für ihn
david greene wir hoffen du siehst zu und
wir wollen wir sagen wir wünschen dir
nur das allerbeste und dass endlich
jemand auf dich aufmerksam wird
bei unserer letzten newcomerin sehen wir
nicht ganz warum sie diesen preis
verdient hätte förderung braucht sie
nicht mehr
denn diese crosspro moore war schon bei
kelly mit den strokes und wie relativ
egal zu sehen wenn ihr vanessa ak mal
wanne trotzdem am 13 juni mit dem preis
zur besten newcomer sehen wollt schaut
in der infobox
denn da ist der link nominierungsliste
bereich das war es auch schon für diese
woche dankeschön an mir relativ egal
gerne stuhl so gut wie diesmal besser
geschafft oder ethernet war mussten wir
ständig laden dieses mal ganz so
wolltest du noch zu sagen abonniert
könnt ihr sie auf ihrem gesicht und
machen wieder bei mir und bei ihr ist
auch ein video und tschüss